Peter Parker continues to have bad luck with
his parents.
While his real mom and dad are long gone,
Spider-Man's real-world guardians Disney and
Sony have been disputing over how best to
look after him.
The web-flinging vigilante is a member of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe thanks to two
Tom Holland-starring films - 2017's Spider-Man:
Homecoming and 2019's Spider-Man: Far From
Home.
He's also made a handful of appearances in
the MCU's ensemble movies - but he's always
remained the property of Sony Pictures.
For months now, Disney, Marvel Studios, and
Sony have been in talks over how to split
financial stakes in the Spider-Man franchise
as they worked to update the shared custody
deal they struck in 2015.
That landmark agreement allowed Marvel to
have access to the Spider-Man character while
Sony retained ownership.
The stand-off reportedly ended on August 20,
when, according to Deadline, the two companies
failed to reach an agreement.
The inability to strike new terms in a deal,
which would have seen Disney obtaining a co-financing
stake in the property, means that Marvel Studios
president Kevin Feige will no longer produce
Spider-Man films.
Furthermore, Marvel will cease any involvement
in the Holland-starring Spidey universe moving
forward - meaning that Spider-Man is swinging
away from the MCU and crawling back into Sony's
web.
Deadline's sources indicated that the talks
ended because of a disagreement over money.
Disney is said to have requested a 50 percent
co-financing stake in future Spider-Man films
- of which there are reportedly two, anticipated
to feature both actor Tom Holland, and Jon
Watts returning in the director's chair.
The talks also involved Disney potentially
extending that stake into other Spider-Man-adjacent
films, like the growing Venom franchise.
A 50 percent stake is a hefty increase from
Marvel Studios' current share of the Spider-Man
movie series, which is "five percent of first
dollar gross" - or the money that a film makes
during its first day out in theaters.
Sony wanted to keep that deal intact, Disney
didn't, and so Disney came forward with its
own proposition.
As Deadline's Mike Fleming Jr. put it, Sony
executives, quote, "turned that offer down
flat" - apparently not even approaching Disney
with a counteroffer.
According to the report, the studio had no
interest in splitting ownership over what
has become its most commercially successful
franchise.
It's probably not a coincidence that just
a day before this news broke, Spider-Man:
Far From Home officially edged out Skyfall
to become Sony's highest-earning movie ever.
Kevin Feige, a big fan of Spider-Man, reportedly
had every intention of continuing to produce
movies featuring the teen hero if Disney and
Sony were able to renegotiate terms.
Sony is clearly confident that the franchise
has a bright future ahead without Feige or
Marvel Studios involved in producing it.
In addition to the now Sony-controlled Spider-Man
sequels, the studio is confirmed to be working
on a sequel to Venom directed by Andy Serkis,
a Morbius: The Living Vampire movie starring
Jared Leto, and a film centered on Kraven
the Hunter.
According to Deadline, they're also still
working on that Black Cat/Silver Sable thing
they've been trying to get made forever.
The big question surrounding this news is
how it will affect the MCU, which has heavily
featured Spider-Man in its overarching narrative
up to this point.
In just a handful of movies, Holland's Spider-Man
went from a spunky kid who played pinch hitter
during one tense airport battle to a universe-travelling
hero who would put his life on the line to
save other people.
Peter Parker also developed a deeply moving
dynamic with Tony Stark, serving as his protégé-on-the-rise
and standing as the closest thing to a son
that Tony ever had.
For Marvel fans, now it looks like they're
both gone.
It seems like Spider-Man will never again
cross paths with other MCU heroes, and will
instead spend his next few movies cozying
up to characters in Sony's Spidey universe.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.